yesterday there was some very
interesting hearings uh in washington dc
uh sort of primarily about the janu what
happened on january 6th and a little bit
later we're going to get to the comments
from donald trump's former acting
uh secretary of defense about when
donald trump finally did say
okay let's bring in the national guard
to clean up what's going on on january
6. we'll get to that later
but one of the really interesting i
don't know if we would call it a side
story it's really kind of a main story
that came out yesterday during the
testimony is that the biden
administration's top law enforcement
officials
including merrick garland um uh the
attorney general
including homeland security secretary
mallorcas and a number of others
they said in no uncertain terms
that white supremacists are the greatest
domestic terrorist threat within the
united states now
if you've been watching my show for a
while or if you're familiar with the
data
on domestic terrorism this would not be
a surprise to you
the story that the right has been
telling for a very long time
is that american muslims
or immigrants from muslim countries even
left-wing eco-terrorists in some
versions of the story are
really the great domestic threat but
when you look at the data
and you look at domestic extremism
incidents you very quickly understand
that the biggest threat
in the united states indeed is white
supremacists
which sometimes overlap with these sort
of patriot and sovereign citizen
anti-government type movements that's
really where the bulk of the threat
comes from and merrick garland said
yesterday to lawmakers quote
domestic violent extremists pose an
elevated threat in 2021
and in the fbi's view the top
domestic violent extremist threat we
face
comes from racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists
specifically those who advocate for the
superiority
of the white race um now
what you are also uh starting to see
is that republicans are having to find a
new way to even talk about this
and uh senator richard shelby for
example
instead of focusing on the level of
threat is trying to make the
administration seem biased in its
priorities and when it was richard
shelby's turn to talk to merrick garland
he asked are you investigating for
example
the protests in portland oregon with the
same
vigor that you're investigating what
happened on january 6. the implication
and wrapped up in that is the
implication and the assumption
that the portland pros protests were
left-wing
violence whereas i guess he sort of
may be conceding that the january 6th
riots were right-wing violence
and merrick garland responded very well
and said quote
we don't care what the ideology is
violations of law are pursued and are
prosecuted
i think it's fair to say that in my
career as a judge and in law enforcement
i have not seen a more dangerous threat
to democracy
than the invasion of the capital that
doesn't mean we don't focus on other
threats
as well and so we we are starting to see
this kind of shift
uh among the right where it's becoming
essentially undeniable
that the bulk of the incidents are these
right-wing patriot
sovereign citizen anti-government um
uh and certainly white supremacists
racially ethnically religiously
motivated
events but what republicans are now kind
of going back to and it's good that
they're having to change what they're
saying even though it's still bogus
is okay well maybe these are the numbers
but what about the attention that's
being paid there are political decisions
that are being made about who to
investigate who to charge etc
and that should be in that should be
looked into but it's sort of like a
welcome to our world moment this is what
many of us have been saying about the
judicial justice
system for a very very long time when
you look at
who actually uh does drugs
has drugs deals drugs versus who is
prosecuted who is policed
what are the sentences that are given
out we've been pointing out that there's
a lack of equity there for a very long
time
along racial lines for sure among class
lines as well as we've discussed so
now unable to continue denying the
empirical reality
of where the greatest number of threats
come from
they are pushed back to having to make
an argument the left has been making
about the justice system for a very long
time
i don't know where this will go but
yesterday's hearings were very
interesting
because they touched on a lot of these
different um
tangential topics they're big topics but
tangential
to the it to the day of january 6th uh
including
investigative priorities for federal law
enforcement including what the biggest
threats are
and a little bit later in the show we
will get to
some of the testimony about the nitty
gritty of what happened on january 6th
send me your thoughts on this you can
find me on twitter at dpakman and
remember that on monday memorial day
it's not this monday
it's not the next monday i think it's
the one after that
monday memorial day we're doing a
one-day membership special
single day membership bomb if you've
been thinking adam
and maybe maybe i'll sign up someday
memorial day is the day to do it because
it will be a beautiful discount okay if
you want to be notified on memorial day
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an ebook or audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video